it's a massive challenge for the  metropolitan police and for me  personally  but we have been preparing for many many  years  there's some very diligent determined  people who put a lot of effort into this  and indeed myself in my previous roles  in the metropolitan police five six  years ago i was involved in some of that  planning and i've been involved in a  review recently  but most of all i have a lot of trust  and confidence in the fantastic police  officers who are going to support this  event and help make it safe and they've  been working with colleagues from  across government and they're all  households and others as you would  expect so we will have a  safe event but we're going to be putting  thousands of offices into this  because of  the level of security required  and the millions of people who want to  pay their respects